How does she convince everyone that she's
good good it's not a thing you are kamala
it is a thing you do i know dressing up as
captain marvel is weird i spend too much time
in fantasy land cool is this
nannies that is just junk
what does it feel like like an idea come to life
everything's changing really
fast if you save one life
you save the world
are you sure that we can keep that on to know mine
that's a lawsuit great that'll make captain marvel
in court it won't be the first case in
the american judiciary to hug it out
you want me to do it yeah okay yeah come on you
did amazing work you've done amazing work and
we'd be honored if you would play a kamala khan
for us in the ms marvel show and it was unanimous
decision oh my god it's like it's pretty cool
right now i can't comprehend this right now
i'm a superhero now so that's normal
another day in the marvel universe
kamala khan is just passionate creative high
school kid she's going through all those awkward
cringe-worthy moments family drama toy troubles
school problems are you following yes keep going
and also she's like a huge fan a huge fan big
fan such a fan she is a fan of captain marvel
iman valani that girl is kamala khan
kamala khan discovers that she has the superpowers
she can manifest light but being a superhero
is not quite as simple kamala's
biggest conflict is with herself
maybe they're right it's not really the brown
girls from jersey city who saved the world
i wish that you would just focus on your story
you're kamala colin you want to save the world
then you're going to sleep do you
know what you are i'm a superhero
despite her superpowers she has a strong heart
it's not about who you look like the clothes you
wear it's about what you do with what you've been
given i can't even put it into words how cold
this is it's it's very my heart is very full
Welcome back everyone this will be my brand
new ms marvel trailer video there's a whole
bunch of easter eggs here for everything that's
going on in this part of the timeline dr strange
multiverse madness thor love and thunder avengers
end game obviously because everything is calling
back to avengers end game and everything
that the avengers have been doing so far
there was also a lot of funny iron man stuff
that they talked about when they were talking
about these episodes so i'll break that down too
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the episodes i will be doing
videos for all the episodes the big reminder too
is that this series is going to overlap with the
obi-wan kenobi episodes for a couple weeks so what
will probably wind up happening is that i'll post
my obi-wan kenobi episodes first in the morning
and then post my ms marvel episode later in the
afternoon there's only going to be a couple weeks
of overlap so it won't be that big a deal but one
of the big things that they talk about during this
is how she's meant to be this fan of captain
marvel but the funny thing that the actress
iman valani talked about is that she was actually
in real life this huge iron man stand so anytime
something really big would happen to her while
they were working on the series like when she
was cast when she was working on the first couple
of episodes she would go back and re-watch the
original iron man film because in real life it's
like her favorite movie that she just goes back
and re-watches all the time solid planned there
because the original iron man movie is one of
the best movies that marvel has ever made but the
funny thing that they said is when they started
working on actual episodes she kept trying to work
in iron man references to all the actual scenes
that she was shooting because if you think about
it in reality iron man is such a huge celebrity
because of what happened during avengers end game
and him sacrificing himself wielding the infinity
gauntlet within the context of the universe around
the world it was such a huge moment people would
just be talking about iron man all the time for
years and years and years the legend of iron man
so just like in real life her character that she's
playing would also be this huge iron man stand
but they said the funny thing is that when they
were shooting the first couple of episodes one of
the notes from kevin feige as he was watching all
the dailies and the footage that they were filming
is that there was too much iron man going on
in the series like no no too much too much
you got too much iron man going on in here
because apparently left and right she just
kept talking about iron man during all the scenes
and as they say during the series they want it
to be like the comic book where this version of
kamala khan ms marvel is more of a captain marvel
fan a lot of you also pointing out the irony
of that statement because in the mcu captain
marvel has only spent like a couple of minutes on
earth tops while she's been actual captain marvel
i'm so sorry i have to deal with this you can
get my number from bruce it was so nice to meet
you yeah i i don't have her number she she does
this a lot so if you really think about it most
people wouldn't really know who captain marvel is
like who who are you talking about that that one
person who was here for a couple minutes i guess
i guess she was pretty cool she kind of helped out
like she was back on earth in the 90s but right
after she figured out how her powers work she
spent the vast majority of her time increased
scroll space over the years trying to get them
to chill out on the cree scroll war which had
been going on for like the last hundred years
so when they make all the jokes like the shangshi
post credit scene where the hook is like uh she
does that all the time like just ducking out on
calls like see you guys bye later give me a call
uh we don't we don't have her number we can't call
her we don't know what's going on the reason she's
not around the reason why she's not in earth's
space is because she's over increased squirrel
space still trying to stop the cree squirrel war
from spilling over the events of this series are
supposed to set her up for a crossover into the
marvel's movie captain marvel 2 and i believe that
during that movie part of the plot is them dealing
with the cree scroll war in a much bigger way than
they have in previous films also setting up some
crossover in connection to the secret invasion
series with nick fury as well i've already done a
couple videos about that they're doing a different
version than the secret invasion from the comics
but there's meant to be a lot of similar easter
eggs for that for instance it seems like amelia
clark is playing the scroll empress during that
i haven't talked a lot about monica rambo either
but obviously she's a big part of this too
during one division monica rambo specifically
had beef with captain marvel because she felt
like she kind of abandoned her family and her
mother in their time of need over the years
like it sounds like she wasn't around for her
mother's death even though monica rambo herself
seems like she got snapped before her mother
died because she woke up in the hospital room
so i think the idea is that she was visiting her
mother then she got snapped you have the five year
time jump and her mother died at some point during
that five year time jump and then when the hulk
snapped the infinity gauntlet and blipped everyone
back that's when she came back it also sounds like
she has beef with her because of all the years
that she grew up at sword with her mother trying
to build the sword agency before they obviously
took a big left turn with tyler hayward but like
you have all these big conflicts all these big
wars that they could have used captain marvel
for so it sounds like they'll address that at
some point during the marvel's movie and the
cool connection to doctor strange too is that
in that 838 universe version of the illuminati
her mother maria rambo had become a version of
captain marvel in that universe that was meant to
be a big deep cut for monica rambo in the comics
they were just using her mother maria rambo for it
in the comics technically monica rambo is the
first female to use the name captain marvel
she wound up using the name long before carol
danvers wound up using it in the comics so they
just wanted to wink at that with this version of
maria rambo captain marvel in this other universe
but because they want kamala khan's ms marvel
character to be such a stand for her character
i think they'll probably have some extra scenes
or some special scenes in the first couple of
episodes to explain how she became such a fan
of her character like there'll be some missing
footage or missing battles that we haven't seen
yet in the marvel movies where she spent more
time on earth that we just haven't seen in the
marvel movies so far or like there's a bunch of
extra stuff that she did during the final battle
in avengers end game that wound up being deleted
scenes little reference in the news caught that
and then she saw that and that's when she became
a huge fan of her character a lot of you are also
picking up spider-man homecoming vibes from the
series and the trailers that's basically how
they're treating her character they're going
with a very spider-man homecoming kind of approach
to her character following her through high school
as she figures out her powers like season one is
her basically figuring out the mega bands and how
these powers work then she'll cross over into the
movies like captain marvel 2 the marvel's movie
maybe a couple other things they might do a
season two and then eventually they'll spin up
for like young avengers stuff because they're
setting up young avengers with a bunch of the
other characters from the team in the comics but
for example she's growing up in jersey city here
this isn't too far from where one division in the
hex happens so i am wondering if they reference
what scarlet witch did because everything on the
series is meant to take place after the events of
spiderman no way home so for example she knows
that spider-man exists he's web slinging around
the city saving people being this vigilante
but because of the spell she doesn't know that
peter parker specifically is spider-man and it
also kind of explains why doctor strange isn't
getting involved too like wait a minute there's
this person with superpowers and jersey city
getting out of control we should probably take
care of that he's busy with scarlet witch what's
happening with the multiverse of madness while
this is going on and then you have the events of
thor love and thunder gore the god butcher so
thor is busy with that there's all this crazy
stuff going on in other parts of the world anytime
something crazy happens in the mcu people always
make the joke where are the avengers why don't
they call the avengers who are still alive to
come handle this even though some of them are dead
some of them are still alive and available to help
they had a couple funny moments during falcon
and winter soldier when they addressed this in
a really offhanded kind of way like what do the
avengers who are still alive consider avengers
level problems and what stuff do they leave for
regular authorities to deal with and usually the
only time they view it as an avengers level
problem when like they actually would come
together is if someone on the level of thanos
showed up or if someone like say scarlet witch
went completely off the rails that's when the
avengers like doctor strange would get involved
if you spotted any other easter eggs in the
trailers that i haven't talked about in my
previous ms marvel videos just write them below
in the comments or if you have any questions
about what's going on with the character and how
she's connected to everything else i just posted
a whole bunch of star wars trailer videos in my
obi-wan videos so click here for all my obi-wan
kenobi episode videos and click here for my brand
new mandalorian season 3 trailer video in easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!